Karissa it seems like uh in this
tournament you have a lot of lives I
don't want to say nine lives but a lot
of lives this one was definitely one of
them because it felt like out of the
opening it was such a difficult such an
uncomfortable position for you and that
was the case all the way through towards
uh the end as well but finally you
managed to pull through your feelings
right
now um yeah it was definitely not my
best chest I'm
not super sure what was going on in the
opening but basically I just kept having
this idea of trying to break with F5
that I couldn't really execute well um
but I think like you know she kind of
misstepped a bit and then allowed me to
open up the position and there's this
interesting thing where she sacrificed
The Exchange yes um at this point
right yeah
and I thought I was doing well here um
but I just blundered after Bishop
G5 um at this point Bishop to F6 was was
this the blunder that you are mentioning
or which one was the blunder just
because this one was a blender cuz it
allows like Knight takes H4 I think and
then um white gets like you know another
pawn more play that sort of thing and
like Queen G7 probably would have killed
uh almost every everything that white
had you're right about that yeah Queen
G7 was a very good move in this
position yeah so after Knight takes H4 I
was kicking myself for like not playing
Queen
G7 and uh after that it's like a lot
more difficult because you know first of
all the pawn on H7 is like a bit of a
shelter for my king so I don't quite
want to take it m um and you know once
her knight from F1 kind of joined the
action it was just super tricky for me
to play I think oh yeah and especially
with this pin on the long diagonal we
were looking at the position and it felt
so unpleasant to have to deal with it
because the Knight was coming to H5 her
Pawn came uh into the mix as well after
the move G4 you must have known that
you're in trouble at that point how do
you keep yourself going how do you keep
yourself finding the best moves in the
position um honestly it's kind of like I
knew that I was like uh worse but I felt
that you know if I could just hold on
for a bit maybe try to get my way into
an end game and keep defending then my
material advantage should eventually
show itself yes um so that was sort of
my goal and you know I think it's like
it's also not super clear how white is
supposed to um kind of find like a
winning blow in even mying one moment
there was this one moment I think think
at this point after Rook to E6 Bishop to
B3 and Rook to G5 she had this move Rook
take C4 did you spot
it no actually I didn't see Rick takes
E4 um I think at this point we're both
in like severe time pressure yes so
we're playing Super quickly 3 um I saw
Rook takes E4 came to me as an idea like
a few moves later um once I sort of like
collected my bearings a bit but um yeah
that probably would have ended me yeah
and you actually set up this very nice
trap now if she goes uh Rook takes E4
you have D takes C4 and queen to E8 did
you spot this
one oh yeah this was uh what I was
playing I think she was intending Rook
takes E4 to yeah um because you know she
played n H5 kind of quickly but then
spent um a lot of time before playing G4
so I think this end game is definitely
um you know once I kind of get into end
game I'm clear so I think you have the
better CH I have good chances here yeah
definitely that was our thought too and
things went completely uh wild at this
point
G5
G6 and this was the moment Rook to C3
was a crucial move but again with only a
few seconds on the clock she played this
move
G6 oh I think she played Queen B8 Queen
B8 first excuse me and now G6
and she was giving you checks but she
was at the same time sacrificing pieces
as well how do you see your chances at
this particular
moment um you know I saw this physician
from before when I played uh before I
played 98 but I couldn't quite think of
anything better um and I was like you
know what maybe there's like a chance
that my king could sort of survive
survive this and it turns out that like
it has a lot of a square to run to and
so even though all of White's pieces are
in the attack it's super difficult to um
actually Checkmate me so uh but at this
point I was just playing on pure
Instinct you know and after Rook G3 King
F6 I felt that um you know she took some
time to think and then I felt that I was
okay yeah I actually thought that I was
um I thought that I was already better
at that point but I guess there was like
some sort of night Tak G7 maybe some
sort of Perpetual yes yes but that's
already not easy with only a few seconds
on the
clock yeah and then I think like she
also expected this position to be
winning it probably threw off her game a
little bit when she realized that
there's like no clear Checkmate yeah so
and after Knight G5 you found the right
move Knight to uh F5 and after that you
got this uh mini gift because your
position is already winning but she did
play the move Knight to H7 probably just
forgetting that the seventh rank has
been
opened and take a look at this because
we wanted to discuss about this with you
as well this is the line scores of your
line score and beim they're
identical when does this ever happened
has it ever happened to
you no I mean no I've never seen
something like this I've also never seen
like a a shared lead after seven out of
eight so um I'm super surprised I think
we're both in really good form but
definitely still have no three rounds to
go good players as well so um it's still
anyone's tournament absolutely
incredible uh line scores
congratulations on another great Victory
Karissa uh go get your rest during the
rest day and we'll see you in a couple
of days thank you our congratulations to
you as well Carissa as we have our
standings